The Daily Mail the world's five nuclear
superpowers are on the brink of a direct
armed conflict which will have
catastrophic consequences the Kremlin
said on Wednesday that avoiding nuclear
Clash was its first priority Western
capitals have said Moscow was behind a
ramping above nuclear rhetoric Russia
said that it stood by a joint
declaration for avoiding a nuclear war I
respect it Vladimir Putin has appeared
on several occasions to threaten a
nuclear strike there's even some
reporting that Putin tried to launch a
nuke but was sabotaged by who we don't
know aliens perhaps perhaps not but uh
that's at least one report said so I'm
wondering uh Lord miles you're actually
on the ground in Ukraine oh yes you've
witnessed a lot of the stuff I'm curious
if you think we're facing an escalation
that could bring us to a nuclear
conflict or will it just remain Regional
what do you think well I think it'll be
good business for me but if I have to
think about what would happen I think it
would be a very small tactical nuke that
might go off but at the same time if you
establish van nuclear will nuclear war
can be done tactically it will open up
the floodgates Pandora's Box and nukes
will start flying I feel like if a U.S
sent a new retaliation you'll probably
hit Twitter HQ before he hits Russia but
I I do think it would happen Putin is
desperate right now he wants this land
he's fantasized about it since the
Soviet Union fell apart and he's
desperate because he realizes the whole
country would turn against him and with
that much pressure on him right now
people don't think straight what if
there's a fast flag what if there's a
strike on Russian soil he he could
probably then rally popular support in
Russia to do whatever he wants yeah I
wouldn't have passed him because the US
government would do this too he might
set off uh it might do a false flag
himself uh cause a nuclear bomb to go
off in some remote area of Siberia
whatever say it was some uh terrorists
going on that have been sent from
Ukraine and then just everyone rallies
behind him and some other countries send
extra troops and I don't think Siberia I
think Moscow you think I mean yeah
absolutely you have a Russian into
knowing known for just throwing away
their men like this right exactly
soldiers yeah the the zap bran again of
of international conflict and also the
other Russians it was the Soviets that
did pretty much the same thing I mean no
Russia's its own Beast sure sure the
Russian people are ancient
well and also there's a possibility that
the opposite of this could happen there
could be a false flag by Ukraine or by
Western Powers inside of Ukraine and
they could blame Russia for it to then
also use that again there's a lot of
potential for false Flags it it it's not
just the United States or Russia or
Ukraine that has the potential of
launching them it's also independent
third parties uh corporations the
military industrial complex that has a
lot to gain and win here but this is an
absolutely crazy disastrous situation
the West is not trying to give any kind
of easy way out for Vladimir Putin
Vladimir Putin has put himself in an
extremely difficult situation there's a
lot of people being negatively affected
by this inside of Ukraine right now
their energy infrastructure has been
targeted they're facing a dark winter to
the point where they're telling their
refugees not to come back to the country
because they won't know if they're going
to have enough energy to heat the
country so this is a major problem this
is a humanitarian crisis this is
something that we need to deal with that
we need to de-escalate and come to a
table where we could negotiate a peace
deal but the exact opposite of that is
happening and they're calling for more
escalations more war more military
contracts which I think is absolutely
stupid I wanna oh are you gonna say
Mouse oh yeah well thank you uh we've
got to realize why the war actually
begun and because Russia fears that NATO
is moving closer and the corridor the
actual uh length of Europe is opening up
for them so they can't defend their
border soon uh easier because it's so
wide if they move further down you know
it's narrower and they can easily defend
that area especially with the
geographical boundaries so if they did
drop tactical nukes in a straight line
down they could claim parts of Ukraine
but also means NATO can't move in even
further and no Army is going to send
their people through a nuclear Wasteland
right they just straight up die from
nuclear radiation poisoning and so on so
it could be the only way he secures
borders and the security of Russia in
general against NATO I mean a
radioactive wall yeah basically I mean
that's what um I think it was Douglas
Arthur fought about with China to
protect
um against uh North Korean aggression
right because China was supplying North
Korea during the Korean War he proposed
worst drop in line of nukes and they
said no that's crazy but trivia could it
could work
it could be scary that it could work to
stop humans from walking maybe but I I
don't know it would be it would just be
insanity and you got the Russians
working with the French on building a
fusion reactor right now that's so weird
they said that they want to avoid at all
costs the the nuclear war I think the
actual what's the quote uh Russia is
strictly and consistently Guided by the
tenet that a nuclear war cannot be won
and must never be fought this is the
Russian foreign Ministry uh according to
NBC News I mean it could be one
it just means that the aftermath is you
live in a bunker for a little while
right and that's not a winning and then
afterwards a few hundred people try to
rebuild Society it's like how even the
poor in modern society are richer than
the richest kings from 500 years ago
we're all winning yeah it's it's
important to note here that a lot of
people escalating this conflict have
nuclear bunkers and they won't have to
deal with the larger consequences of the
larger problems of them escalating this
conflict sorry Ian I wanted to clarify
this statement about the Soviet Union
and Russia and how they're different
it's kind of like if the Nazis had won
World War II and created a new country
called or New Empire called the Third
Reich and Germany was part of the Third
Reich and then so the Soviet Union was
like the Third Reich it was this weird
totalitarian regime that took over
Russia and all these foreign other
countries so now we finally got rid of
like the Soviet Nazi party and now we're
back to like what Germany would be if we
had dispelled the not the Third Reich
later it would still have like remnants
of it but it's Germany is not the third
right but but Ian the Soviet Union was
largely Russia
with satellite States yeah they used
Russia that the Bolsheviks used Russia
they definitely took it but it wasn't
like like are Germans still German after
World War II yeah when the fall of the
Soviet Union happened Russia was the
centerpiece and that is literally The
Remnant core of the Soviet Union yeah
yeah it is Vladimir Putin was KGB yeah
right it'd be like if if we finally got
rid of the Third Reich seven 20 years
ago they'd be like yeah he used to be a
Nazi well duh that was the government of
the Third Reich and when we mentioned
the tactics of the Nazis we'd be like
that was Germany that the country that
still exists yeah it was the Nazis that
had usurped the German Throne miles if I
could just ask you really quickly from
your experiences on the ground there
were people worried about this
escalating were people worried about
nuclear explosions and tactical nukes
when you were there what was the what
was the gist of what people were seeing
there and what they were thinking was
going to happen there so I was speaking
mainly to the women and children at
first and a lot of them don't have a
hoping War because they know their
governments like Ukraine is very corrupt
in general and I'm pro-ukraine but you
know they have a lot of issues so they
don't think that Ukraine's gonna be uh
acting in their best interests in
general and they talked about the idea
of a nuclear weapon going off because
they know if a nuclear weapon goes off
um that the Ukrainian uh government will
get tons of funding and support and
everything like they're doing now so
it'll probably let it happen or even
escalate it to that point on purpose
that's all some of their theories and
some are soldiers are speaking on my
front lines of card keeper saying yeah
we we seeing this right now we're
actually winning we can see them being
squeezed basically and when they get
squeezed they go panic and something
will be set off but they also told me
how the nuclear weapon system works in
in Russia so in the US you know Joe
Biden he has a Joe Biden moment maybe
presses a butter driver he has a nuclear
football exactly births in in Russia how
he works is the president's calls up uh
you know nuclear submarine goes uh ring
ring hello uh nuke please and then all
those people have to agree on it so
there's a two-step verification
three-step verification system actually
yeah it's I think it's like someone in
the general assembly and then they have
to so it's a number of people that do
have to agree that they're going to be
launching the nuke and this could be why
allegedly we're hearing reports again
I'm very skeptical whenever we hear you
know Putin was sabotaged here and here
because again you can't trust a lot of
these reports there's no evidence behind
them but it's three phone calls that
need to be made and three uh different
groups of people that have to decide yes
we're launching this nuke exactly yeah
unlike the United States where Biden
just brings in the nuclear football
launch exactly yeah and you gotta think
of a psychology of these people so these
ordinary people working for military in
a nuclear memory not earning so much you
gotta think okay well they were in the
Soviet Union obviously because they've
climbed so high since then and those
were the Glory Days where things were a
lot better than they are now right
um and they had that national pride they
thought they were top of the world they
were a superpower at that point and now
they're probably demoralized and they're
thinking well you know is it really
worth launching a nuke do I really
believe in my leader is our country
still great right now it's like
America's problem as well so I honestly
think it might just stop they might
order a nuke event they say hell no I
don't want uh my women
um back home my mother my wife my sister
to get nuked by the opposite country
because you know nuclear change I think
one thing we we uh we didn't consider
about nuclear war is that by the time we
would ever reach this kind of this level
of Crisis our cultures would have
decayed to the point where no one cares
enough about each other for this to
matter
so you know even in Russia they're
experiencing cultural Decay across
Europe it's cultural decay in the United
States it's cultural decay
I'd imagine you know in the 50s people
were much more like America like as a
nation much more unified not anymore I
mean America's Americans are each
other's throats and it's not even just
the left and the right they're
sub-factions of leftists fighting
Democrats and Libertarians arguing with
conservatives into varying degrees it's
serious
I can't imagine that someone's gonna be
like I have to do this to save my people
they're going to be like what people I
want to be rich you know a lot of people
have been dehumanized and I think that's
another aspect that we should understand
here when it comes to this kind of proxy
war that has people killing each other
in the fields uh there's a great movie
that just came out on Netflix uh what
was it called everyone's talking about
it right now the world war one movie
World War One movie uh absolutely great
movie and it shows you the the shocking
horror of realities and how these
politicians and these bureaucrats and
their High towers that are literally
deciding you know what
just go kill each other just go murder
each other and that is just and the
movie critiqued that very heavily uh All
Quiet on the Eastern Front All Quiet on
the Western Front definitely worth the
watch to understand here because the
same footage that I saw in that movie
it's the same footage that I'm seeing
when I'm trying to do my research on
what's happening in Ukraine and watching
the footage from the Russians and the
ukrainians it's almost identical when it
comes to because of the bombing the
trench warfare the the hand-to-hand
combat that you sometimes see the the
blood the explosions it's it's it's
something that is absolutely
uncomfortable unnatural for Humanity to
deal with this is why a lot of people
have PTSD this is why the the human body
isn't you know destined is is it okay
with killing another human being but for
some reason when someone puts on a
special costume in a uniform and tells
someone else to do it they do it that is
a stupid asinine idea that is
dehumanizing that is absolutely stupid
and backwards it needs to be challenged
more than ever right now well but I mean
you know there's too many people gotta
Bloom up right that's what Bill Gates
would said and Barack Obama I guess yeah
during covert right you mentioned
earlier that we're in a state of
cultural Decay I'm starting to think
it's not that but more that we're in a
state of cultural shock like the globe
has has we're basically all these
cultures have come face to face with
each other now we have communism in the
United States we've got uh American
republicanism in in in Iran we have
people doing like the the Arab Spring
people are like hell no I want to be a
republic and so we've got like it's this
like it is demoralizing shock in a lot
of ways but it's just it's just like uh
like the paddles have just shocked the
uh it's a new organism a cultural
organism uh it can be a little it can it
can be a little harsh but uh but it's
like thinking that way has it so I'm not
so upset about the communism in American
schools and in American politics like
it's a natural part of the cultures
coming face to face this is just part of
it and it's up to us to stay positive to
have morale high so that our culture
comes out on top thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there